john i know that today is very special  for you because it's your daughter's  first birthday  you know going into that you said that  it was going to be hard to not be there  but how special was it to walk off the  court with the win with your daughter's  name on your shoes to  on her birthday  i'll just start by thanking you know my  whole staff here  um my teammates for helping make this  day even more special for me  this morning i woke up i wasn't in a  good mood at all  i talked with my parents told him it's  probably one of the toughest days of my  life  not being able to be at my daughter's  first birthday party  it's kind of tough but um  i think the gift i gave her to today was  a win  so hopefully she's thankful for that and  all the gifts she got back at the house